when billionaire Elon Musk bought
Twitter some Tesla investors worried
musk was abandoning the electric vehicle
maker to focus on the social media
company
so in Twitter uh what could possibly go
wrong
since the deals closed in late October
Tesla shares have slipped ending the
year down 65 percent the company's worst
year on record but the reason for the
sell-off goes far beyond Twitter here's
what drove Tesla investors away in 2022
and what's affecting the car maker going
into 2023. let's start with demand
for years Tesla has stood out as the
leader in the electric vehicle space and
while its dominance continued in the
third quarter of 2022 its market share
slipped to 61 percent in the last year
we've seen an explosion of competing EV
models for Tesla and as that number
continues to grow over the years the
concern is whether or not demand for
Tesla vehicles will continue to stay as
high as it has been in the past
according to JD Power there were 33 EV
models available in the US at the end of
2021 but by the end of 2022 that number
had jumped to 53 models Tesla still held
four of the top five selling EVS last
year according to s p Global Mobility
but the sell-off in Tesla shares
reflects investors fear that its hold
won't last as newer models arrive Tesla
has sold the same sort of handful of
models for years now and the question is
will Tesla continue to be as competitive
as it has in the past or will they
become outdated further fueling concern
are customer wait times for Tesla cars
which dropped sharply over 2022. some
investors see this as a signed demand is
already softening musk addressed these
concerns on Tesla's third quarter
earnings call I can't emphasize enough
we have excellent demand for Q4 and we
expect to sell uh every car that we make
for that as far into the future as we
can see and in December the CEO set out
on our Twitter space is called that
near-term demand pressures were driven
by Rising interest rate policies
production disruptions also contributed
to the stock slide last year leading to
Tesla missing its full year vehicle
delivery Target the EV maker said it
delivered 1.3 million vehicles in 2022
up 40 from 2021. that was shy of its
goal of increasing deliveries by 50 or
more it would have needed more than 1.4
million to hit that Target news of the
shortfall push stocks down another 12
percent to start the new year its
largest single day decline in more than
two years intermittent Factory closures
at Tesla's China plant its largest by
volume were one part of the problem
China's zero covered policy led to a
number of shutdowns at its Factory in
Shanghai which obviously created
supplies of its own Tesla also faced
issues at new factories in Texas and
Germany where it struggled to ramp up
production musk addressed those problems
in a May interview both Berlin and
Austin factories are gigantic money
furnaces right now Rising supplier and
Logistics costs combined with soaring
inflation contributed to these
production setbacks Tesla in every
manufacturer making EVS today is
confronting rapidly Rising costs from
the raw materials that go into the
batteries to construction related costs
or frankly even labor-related costs all
of that is going up and the car industry
is not one with huge profit margins for
Tesla this included spending roughly 11
billion dollars in the first quarter on
items needed to make and sell cars
overwhelmingly our concern is how do we
keep the factories operating so we can
pay people and not go bankrupt
overvaluation is another Factor some
investors and analysts say is
complicating Tesla's shrinking stock
price Tesla has been egregiously
overvalued for the last couple years
based on site at its peak Tesla was
worth more than the 10 largest
automakers on the planet combined
despite having just a fraction of their
sales a lot of investors who have
debated whether or not Tesla is an
overvalued company
have done so based on the fact that it
owned a huge percentage of the US EB
market and that it was the first mover
in that market its valuation was driven
in part by its CEO and some investors
say musk's promises about future
vehicles have pushed shares higher
though many of the cars didn't come
until years later the latest example
Tesla's cyber truck which was first
unveiled three years ago and still
hasn't hit the market cyber truck is
going to be
it's worth the wait believe me and more
directly musk's move to offload billions
in Tesla stock in part related to
Twitter has pushed down Tesla's share
price anytime anybody sells 40 billion
dollars with a company stock it's gonna
bring that stock price down what isn't
clear is how that specific action is
influencing other investors Tesla did
not respond to requests for comment
Tesla's stock sell-off comes as
investors across the market prepare for
what some see as an oncoming recession a
downturn could slow car buying
especially for pricier Vehicles will
those people who might otherwise in 2022
or 2021 purchase a 60 000 vehicle will
they instead purchase a forty thousand
dollar gas powered vehicle on Tesla's
third quarter earnings call musk said
that he sees the EV company as recession
resilient let's say 2023 is a is a
brutal recession year even then
regenerate vehicle cash Tesla investors
are now waiting for later this month
when the car maker will report its full
year earnings which could give a glimpse
of the Stock's prospects for the coming
year
foreign